on l'invité politique du jour annie
genevard députés l ère du doubs et
présidente des républicains bonjour
annie genevard la bataille pour la
présidence dlr retailleau ciotti pradier
les républicains peuvent-ils encore joué
un grand rôle dans la politique
française un scénario à l'italienne avec
alliance avec le rnd ou à la britannique
avec les conservateurs quelle solution
si face à la crise de l'énergie et
pourquoi le boycott du conseil national
de la refondation tant de questions que
nous allons essayer de voir l'or c'est
donc la course à la présidence qui était
en toile de fond du campus des jeunes
républicains ce week-end à angers trois
noms ressortent gelé dit bruno
retailleau eric ciotti aurélien pradié
on avait murmuré audi votre nom à un
moment donné ça vous vous y avait
renoncé pour l'instant je n'ai pas
encore apporté ma réponse je savais
c'est ça quand on préside il faut
pouvoir être un peu au dessus de la
mêlée et
pour l'instant on vole et d'arbitrer
cette compétition car c'est une
compétition évidemment mais ça ne doit
pas être une guerre donc moi je suis un
peu la garante de l'unité oui mais vous
n'excluez pas l'instant je ne ressens
pas cette question j'y répondrai oui
sens qu'en attendait mais quand même
bruno retailleau eric ciotti aurélien
pradié je ne vois pas de femmes c'est
vrai c'est vrai d'ailleurs hier dans mon
discours j'ai invité à la fois les
jeunes républicains et l'ensemble des
républicains bien considérer que notre
mouvement ne peut pas se rénover se
refonder se moderniser ci ne laisse pas
davantage de place aux femmes
donc
candidat non il y à des femmes dans nos
instances dirigeantes bien sûr j'en suis
là le témoignage mais je pense que
voilà merci mais quelle image vous allez
offrir le parti des républicains si vous
n'avez pas de femmes candidates je
n'aurais pas accepté la candidature de
virginie calmels dire j'en conviens mais
être une femme ne suffit pas à soi tout
seul de donner une légitimité à sur la
candidature de virginie calmels je vous
savez qu'elle présentait un problème de
calendrier la haute autorité puisque
c'est elle qui a la main sur ce sujet a
considéré que sa candidature n'était pas
recevable mais vous avez raison je pense
qu'on a on a vraiment des marges de
progression mais tous les partis
politiques vous savez ont des marges de
progression pour laisser des places à
hautes responsabilités aux femmes donc
pour l'instant vous vous êtes au dessus
à gérer dit voilà c'est ça ne va pas au
dessus des partis mais au dessus de la
mêlée au dessus de la mêlée voilà c'est
ça mais le cas échéant vous pour gérer
leur compte et j'apporterai ma réponse
très bientôt très bientôt je clarifierai
les sur vous pourriez être candidate
annie genevard c'est ce qu'on retient
fin ce matin écoutez ces tensions
potentiellement oui c'est vous ne vous
ne la rejetez pas pourquoi laurent
wauquiez n'est pas candidat lui
d'abord cette décision lui appartient il
en a lié les clés mais si je comprends
bien
d'abord il a déjà exercé cette fonction
c'est toujours difficile de revenir un
de se baigner dans le même fleuve
et puis je crois que il a intégré l'idée
que les parties n'étaient peut-être plus
les incubateurs de présidentiable leur
rôle est peut-être ailleurs et en tout
état de cause une présidentielle c'est
la rencontre entre un homme ou une femme
et le peuple la rencontre s'est pas avec
le parti qu'elle se fait c'est avec une
personne donc qu'ils veuillent
s'abstraire de 2,2 considérations
strictement partisanes ça peut se
comprendre ça peut se comprendre mais
c'est en tout cas c'est son choix et je
le respecte et les candidats à cette
présidence a eu pour ont très bien
travaillé avec lui quel qu'il soit s'ils
sont élus par la suite quoi moi mais de
toute façon il faudra qu'on se met en
ordre de bataille beaucoup plus tôt
qu'on ne l'a fait pour cette dernière
présidentielle
je pense que les primaires sont vraiment
une machine à perdre
donc il faudra qu'on trouve les voies et
moyens pour se mettre d'accord autour
d'un candidat ou d'une candidate est
suffisamment tôt oui c'est ça 2027 se
prépare maintenant coin avec que cette
candidate enfin cette présidence quoi
épier la mise en ordre on marche si je
puis dire de des républicains alors le
parti extrêmement important un certain
considère qu' on vit la fin des parties
non pas du tout
d'abord parce qu'une pensée politique un
projet politique débat démocratique
ce père ou au sein d'un parti il n'y a
pas de partie qu'est ce qui est le
support des groupes parlementaires par
exemple donc simplement le fait que les
présidentiables ne veulent pas en
prendre la tête implique que l'on re
définissent le rôle des partis essaient
et c'est quelque chose de relativement
nouveau dans notre famille politiquement
et annie genevard où se situe le parti
face à la majorité actuelle c'est cette
question du positionnement est ce que
vous êtes une véritable opposition une
force d'un point alors on ne veut
surtout pas être une force d'appoint
parce que évidemment c'est ce que c'est
ce dont nous accuse le rassemblement
national
et c'est ce que voudrait la majorité
présidentielle au fond tous les deux
s'entendent pour vouloir notre mort il
faudrait s'interroger sur les raisons
pour lesquelles ils veulent notre mort
parce que finalement on est le dernier
obstacle
emmanuel macron
voudrait nous rallier pour faire une
majorité qu'il n'a pas et on n'a pas
vocation à être les supplétifs de la
majorité donc nous on a joué notre rôle
d'être utile aux français on a fait
voter des mesures on a obtenu par la
force par la voir le rapport de force
politique
l'obtention d'un certain nombre de
mesures la défiscalisation le
multinational rtt donc on a joué de
troll maintenant la livre votre mort
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure en a
pas on n'a pas tout compris qui veut
votre morceau alors moi je pense que le
rassemblement national
nous tape dessus depuis des années parce
que ils veulent que l'on disparaissent
du paysage politique pour se substituer
à nous et c'est exactement la même
volonté du côté de la majorité
présidentielle lorsque bruno le maire
dit très maladroitement que les députés
les républicains se sont alliés à la
majorité ce qui est faux absolument faux
c'est aussi une autre façon de vouloir
nier or moi je pense que l'existence de
l air est absolument indispensable au
débat démocratique à la vitalité
démocratique alors annie genevard il va
y avoir un moment important là c'est le
vote du budget qu'est ce que vous allez
qu'est ce que vous vous allez faire
alors sur ce vote du budget alors qu'il
ya un appel du pied de la majorité et
bien sûr la majorité nanette n'étant pas
n'ayant pas la majorité absolue a besoin
de trouver des voies écoutez c'est assez
basique moi j'ai dirigé un exécutif soit
vous voter le budget et vous êtes dans
la majorité soit vous êtes dans
l'opposition et vous vous opposez au
budget parce que je veux tu es le budget
ça veut dire tout partagé de la majorité
la méthode les options les objectifs
nous nous n'avons pas nous ne
préconisons pas les mêmes orientations
devraient être du côté par exemple de la
nuque ce qui est qui va vers le blocage
est contre ce budget plutôt que d'être
avec la majorité actuelle pousse à
éviter la même chose c'est pas voté la
même chose pour les mêmes raisons vous
avez trois votes possibles à l'assemblée
pour contrer abstentions mais après le
le le la motivation du vote évidemment
elle est profondément différente chez
nous et chez les autres oppositions
questions très concrètes aussi la
prolongation du bouclier tarifaire pour
2023 c'est une bonne chose ou pas ajouté
j'entends je ne sais pas comment le
gouvernement va faire parce que le
bouclier tarifaire c'était une bonne
chose ça permet d'abord de juguler un
peu l'inflation elle est plutôt moins
forte chez nous et d'éviter
l'emballement prix prix salaires mais
elle a un gros inconvénient c'est qu'il
coûte
cela coûte très très cher plus de 20
milliards en donc c'est quelque chose
qui ne pourra pas être
reproduit à l'infini d'autant que la
majorité comment faisait a annoncé que
pas de dette et pas d'impôt
supplémentaire donc c'est un peu la
quadrature du cercle mais vous savez
cette question énergétique pour moi ce
sera d'ailleurs la question majeure
crucial de la rentrée ce gouvernement
élu et le précédent et la précédent par
nature ont fait n'importe quoi en
matière énergétique
on a affaibli comme jamais la filière
nucléaire qui fournissent l énergie
décarbonée pas cher on a ruiné et df qui
n'a plus les moyens de faire ce qu'elle
devrait faire pour rénover le parc
nucléaire donc forcément aujourd'hui on
est au pied du mur et on est coincé et
moi ce que j'attends
concrètement sait déjà que la france
pèse de tout son poids au niveau
européen pour revoir le couplage
électricité gallas si on ne fait pas ça
c'est on court à la catastrophe
des chefs d'entreprises nous appellent
complètement affolé les contrats
proposés par edf sont multipliées par
dix et sera en mourir est ce les
entreprises et un temps sourit annie
genevard est ce que emmanuel macron est
à la hauteur de ce défi parce que j'ai
vu dans un tweet que vous dit qu'il a un
don pour la pro krasny une pro cranie
station pardon pour gastro graciation on
va dire on va donc le fait de remettre
au lendemain
savez ce que j'observe c'est que on a
fait des ségur des beauvau des grenelles
des grands débats des états généraux et
même aujourd'hui le conseil national de
la refondation toutes ses instances où
l'on parle au lieu de faire moi je pense
que le temps est venu de faire le
diagnostic
il est connu on sait tout de ce qu'il
faudrait faire il faut agir il faut agir
alors moi je trouve que
il ya vraiment un problème de méthode là
qui interroge et qui inquiète parce que
dans le contexte il faut vraiment
retrousser ses manches et agir et voyez
par exemple madame bornes madame la
première ministre ne semble pas faire
par exemple de la réforme des retraites
une de ses priorités on sait que c'est
une urgence budgétaire moi je suis très
inquiète de voir repousse enfin des
réformes qui sont indispensables à
neutre dont c'est pour çà a ni jo de
voir que vous êtes d'accord avec ceux
qui vont boycotter le conseil national
de leur fondation jeudi alors les
républicains de en ma personne puisque
je préside le parti ne participeront pas
au conseil national de la
''refondation'' d'abord parce que son
contour
à la fois son objet et son contour
politique est extrêmement apprécié ces
c'est pour parler du constat que chacun
connaît ça ne sert à rien et puis c'est
une façon de contourner de le parlement
c'est choquant c'est contraire à nos
institutions donc nous avons décidé de
ne pas y participer
ça c'est définitif quoi j'ai juste sur
le budget alors cessé non ou abstention
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure ce sera un
qu'elle sera d'abord il faut avoir le
texte oui d'abord il faut avoir le texte
moi je ne me prononce jamais avant de
voir le texte mais quand je vois quand
j'entends le porte parole du
gouvernement nous détailler les
orientations budgétaires des principaux
ministères je ne vois quasiment enfin je
ne vois pas d'économie genevois je ne
vois que des dépenses supplémentaires
donc je vois pas comment ce budget va
pouvoir tenir ses promesses de
d'assainissement des comptes publics on
va voir ce que dit le texte et on va
voir comment ce riante le débat mais en
tout étaient plus quand même vers
l'abstention ou le malheur la jeune ce
sujet on ne votera pas selon toute
probabilité
nous ne ferons pas le budget ne
partageant ni la méthode ni les
orientations du gouvernement
un mot sur michel onfray avec son front
populaire qui veut se lancer dans la
course aux européennes qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire
quand les intellectuels sortent de leur
zone de
jallet dire de confort c'est courageux
mais
son âme la souveraineté dit il oui non
mais bien sûr cette question de la
souveraineté ce que je trouve
sympathique c'est que au fond il est
authentiquement préoccupé par le destin
de la france et la question de la
souveraineté est en effet une question
absolument fondamental on voit que dix
ans de socialisme macro nisme on
affaiblit terriblement la souveraineté
absolument à tous les niveaux donc
maintenant
chacun est libre en france de se
présenter dernière question annie
genevard une question sur les femmes en
politique sandrine rousseau se veut le
porte drapeau aujourd'hui
alors bon moi je trouve que c'est un
féminisme très caricatural d'ailleurs
elle est moqué en permanence c'est un
féminisme très excluant aussi un c'est
les femmes contre les hommes alors bien
sûr les les droits des femmes doivent
encore être défendus combelles pas
améliorée
et le sexisme le machisme les violences
faites aux femmes enfin tout ça
malheureusement existe et nécessite un
combat résolu et est sans faille
maintenant c'est de cette image moi je
me reconnais pas du tout dans dans ce
féminisme là je pense que notre devise
républicaine si on l'appliquait ou femme
se serait déjà très bien merci annie
genevard présidente des républicains et
député du doubs qui était l'invité ce
matin de sud radio